do we have sky news with us
yes you do
thank you very much for taking my
question
britain's defense secretary has said
that vladimir putin has gone full tonto
that is english slang for completely mad
senator that's a view of many people
looking at this he's launched an
unprovoked attack on a southern
neighbour that is killing a lot of
ukrainian
cousins of russia and russian soldiers
what's your reaction to that description
of his action
no it was late yeah well you know
it's surprising that such evaluations
given by
defense minister of the uk regarding
authorities of a different state
i think he could have
thought up of similar
adjectives
thinking of british prime minister if we
talk about personal uh
judgment
and if we talk about the operation and
that there are people dying then yes
unfortunately
this is
a huge tragedy that
there is a need to resort to such
methods
and this is exactly what
we talked about during eight years eight
years of our policy of our efforts
our work
24 7.
that's what it took to demonstrate that
the peaceful
resolution of this
high tension
conflict which in 2015 was already a
bloodbath
priority
problem that any
other than dialogue is tragic in its
nature and should be avoided and could
you please say how many
years must it have taken
must have this bloodshed gone on in
eastern ukraine five ten years
why did you start
counting victims only today or say
yesterday
who gave you the right to ignore
victims especially we were talking about
thousands of them over all these years
isn't your conscience tormenting you
when you're western journalists
speculating
peaceful citizens closing bags every day
you never counted them
just like president zielenski
never consider them people
who gave you the right to speak of the
victims starting only today
that's the way you
create your reports if that's your
approach to it you're not journalists
and you're not people
13 000 people
and i am not dividing them although in
honesty i would very much like to
and maybe should have in those who shot
first and those who were
members of
ukrainian military men or their regular
army and nationalist battalions which
then became part of their armed forces i
did not divide them
from
civilians
and from the people which you call
militias separatists
13 000 people died and osc had no
opportunity to
account for every
why didn't you ask these questions in
kiev why didn't you
broadcast people in donbass why did you
give them no opportunity to attend
international organizations meetings or
join in
online you have no conscience at all
maybe you should first
calculate the number of
the people which died at the hands of
the british
authorities in iraq how many people died
there on the orders of
downing streets how many civilians died
and how many british military men died
would you like to talk about afghanistan
because
well time for that so before you
judge others start with yourself
and if you talk about the situation in
ukraine and
the actions of russia in protecting
peaceful citizens of donbass you
shouldn't start counting with february
2022.
this history
is many years old at least you should
start with 2013 and the last thing i
would like to say
you'd like to count the citizens which
died did you count the people that died
on maidan in 2013 2014 how many people
died how many people were killed by
snipers how many
once during those years so it's not for
you to say that there is an operation
conducted it's not
beginning of a war it's an operation to
end a war which has been going on for
many years and ignoring it and not
recognizing it is just as criminal as
servicing informationally kievan regime
and i am sorry for my emotion but
this
has been overdue and we do not want to
listen to and trust your mass media we
will respond to your questions but
such starting points and such approaches
is are unacceptable because what you do
is propaganda and
it was fun with propaganda in other
spheres but when you tied to
promotion of war which
for two months you have been
escalating this is just inadmissible and
then you twist it all and blame the
victims i am sorry
if i could answer any of that please
suck her over
no
no
you're saying that you were prepared to
go and talk with the ukrainian regime in
minsk uh but the terms of those talks
seem to be um the total surrender of
ukraine you're saying it needs to be
following demilitarization how can that
be acceptable to president zielenski if
you're asking him to surrender before he
even begins negotiating with you
wait you said that
you heard me
russia
was ready to send an interagency
delegation to
negotiations in minsk we have declared
that
we just mentioned
it was said by
the press secretary of our president and
and
from mfa i can also say that it is true
such work
can start any time
the only question is that
whether this the other side under the
influence of the west will start to
trying to whistle out or lie or you
yourselves the representative or
representatives of the kieran regime
would
start
contradicting and
debunking each other i just mentioned
the declaration by coleba this is not
something i
made up this was reported by various
news agencies they have to determine
their position
are we talking about negotiations or are
we
embracing some accusations against our
country
as i understand dimitri pescove the
kremlin spokesman has said that these
talks can go ahead once ukraine has
demilitarized
surely that's just demanding their
complete surrender before talks have
even begun
we have mentioned that we are already
ready and obviously the objectives which
have been put forward by the president
before the implementation of the
corresponding
special operation
of course they have not been cancelled
by anyone yes
they are relevant still but the issue is
that we have
reacted to corresponding requests on the
part of president zilean we saw his
video and gave a reaction which
corresponded
can you explain how you're describing
this as the end of the war when it could
be the beginning of the biggest military
offensive we've seen in europe since
world war ii
could you repeat please reframe your
question
thank you you've described this as the
end of the war but it could be the
beginning of the biggest military
campaign
well no i'm not going to to fantasize
this this has nothing to do with the
situation at hand we are pursuing a
stage by stage
approach
the operation is ongoing it has
stated objectives ministry of defense is
making its its comments and we just
recently
uh seen in this statement by vladimir
zilensky we have responded to it uh
well we are not going to to fantasize
again there was a request responded to a
request end of story